my opponent tonight is Jason Kander
president of let America vote here's all
you need to know let America vote is an
organization that fights voter
suppression which is weird I've never
had any problem voting he's a former
Army captain who served in Afghanistan
as general of this TV show I expect a
firm salute in one of Barack Obama's
final interviews as president he
described him as one of the rising stars
in the Democratic Party
look out Canada Oprah Booker Kaepernick
Dunham Jason Kander everybody
so they said you made a splash with a
campaign ad back in 2016 you're running
for Senator in Missouri let's take a
look at it I also believe in background
checks so the terrorists can't get their
hands on one of these I approve this
message
because I'd like to see senator blunt do
this okay
Wow Wow we like guns who respond to guns
but you're a Democrat with a gun wearing
a blindfold what was the point of that
you wear the blindfold because you
didn't want to make eye contact with the
gun what's going on there why I didn't
want it to get weird
yeah no Democrat holding a gun
automatically it's weird no the point of
it was that like the NRA was saying and
they were spending millions of dollars
pointing out that I had an F rating from
the NRA which I proudly have and you
know we wanted to respond and the way I
wanted to respond was to say look yeah
I'm for background checks and the NRA is
wrong about this and also I know what
the heck I'm talking about so that's
what that ad was what you don't know
what that you're talking about you were
anti guns America is all about
guns in the Second Amendment well I mean
I think given the fact that I carried
one it's part of my job I felt like I
was in a position to sort of talk about
why it was important that we not for
instance let terrorists get a hold of a
gun like that
now you after this ad it was got a
little bit of bus president obama said
you were the future of the Democratic
Party what is the future of the
Democratic Party because you lost that
election so if that's the future great
I'm all-in
look I think right now the future is
pretty great I mean I've been in 33
states talking to Democrats in the last
year people are fired up what I'm
excited about with regards to how
excited people are is really just that
it's not like a politician on TV that's
bringing people out into the movement
it's somebody down the street from them
saying hey I'm going to this townhall
I'm gonna demand answers about
healthcare why don't you go with me even
though we're in a super red district why
don't you come over and make phone calls
with me that's what's bringing people
and and I think that's pretty exciting
you're focusing right now on voter
suppression yeah but what's wrong with
making it hard for people to vote don't
we want the best people to vote well you
actually sort of nailed what is the
Republican strategy on this because I
think looking right because they think
that the best people for voting are
people who vote Republican and so the
entire strategy from the Republicans is
to say that they're gonna make it harder
to vote for people who don't vote
Republican and I think that's on America
I think we should let every eligible
voter boat that's why I started let
America vote to create consequences
politically for people who are making it
harder to vote but the purpose of voting
is to win I think being a winner is
being an American that's just the
Republicans being winners that's the
right strategy like oh let everybody win
like okay let Republicans take the house
again see I think that what it is to be
American is to say that you know let's
have everybody get in there and make
their argument we'll let every eligible
voter actually participate as opposed to
saying let's change the rules of the
election let's play a bunch of tricks so
that we can win without actually having
to sell anybody on our argument which is
I think what the Republicans are doing
but Trump disbanded the Commission to
explore voter fraud so aren't we done
with that like we just assumed three
million illegal votes for Hillary but
let's move on so I'm glad you brought
that up because when President Trump
said that there were three to five
million illegal votes in the election
that's actually in my mind the biggest
lie that a sitting president has ever
told and I think when he told that a lot
of people went okay well here's just a
guy who lost the popular vote by about
that amount and he's making this up and
and that's a reasonable take away from
it but the rest of the story is is that
he's really trying to undermine faith in
American democracy so he can put laws in
place that make it harder to vote for
people who are really unlikely to vote
for him that's really the key to his
reelection strategy so
what does your organization what are you
actively doing so we create political
consequences for folks who make it
harder to vote basically if you are a
Republican politician out there right
now trying to keep people from voting we
want to keep you from getting reelected
we knocked on 200,000 doors in the
November elections last year we're
expanding to five states what our boots
on the ground organization that is out
there making sure that there are
consequences for this for the first time
politically you also have a podcast I do
know as a liberal are you are you like
contractually obligated to have a
podcast how does that work no yeah it's
part of the deal yeah the deal yeah and
it's great it's like yes it's also huge
money like the jet is great I can only
imagine you got a public service and
podcast yeah like smart you're clearly
not a conservative yeah my in-laws are
super pumped about why podcast cuz you
want like pretentious people to listen
to you is that what it is would be nice
no no look as I get around the country
one of the most common questions that I
get from people is how do I talk to my
aunt who voted for Trump how do I stay
friends with my friend from high school
who I love voted for Trump and look I'm
somebody who in the election even though
we didn't win I went over a lot of
people who also voted for Trump without
you know changing my values at all and I
realized that if we could tell the
stories of people who are living
divisive issues every day of their life
stuff like college affordability stuff
like you know race and policing that
kind of thing then we would give people
a greater but greater ability to
communicate with folks in a way that
doesn't drive them apart or cause them
to have to just agree when they don't
really agree like pretend they agree do
you think there is common ground to be
had there's all this conversation but
how do I talk to somebody on the other
side I don't I don't understand how they
voted for that one person is there a
common ground to be had there yeah and
the key is to tell your own story like I
refer to this as showing your math
because like when I was in school I
wasn't very good at math and I realized
that if I like showed my journey on the
way to my answer that sometimes the
teacher would give me like a partial
credit for it so it's the same thing
it's if somebody if you're saying
something to somebody and they don't
really agree with your position you got
to tell them how you got there you got
to tell them what it is in your life
that brought you to that point it's
showing your math and it causes people
to kind of let their barriers down and
it's sort of what we show on the podcast
sure it's a podcast where you tell
people to talk to people that they don't
understand
and in order to connect with them they
have to show their math yeah yeah it's
like you're gonna get a tunnel you're
gonna get a tunnel listeners let me tell
you there's no math involved oh man or
anything you don't have to do any math
no huh tell me something I already know
54% of the country voted for somebody
not named Donald Trump in 2016 and the
reason that's important is because it
means that even if he won the election
he didn't win the argument about who
America is or where we're going and
there's a movement happening in the
country right now that 54% is growing
even more and the most effective
movements in the history of this country
are the ones that start not in
Washington and go out but the ones that
start everywhere else and go to
Washington so people should get involved
because it's an exciting movement to be
a part of and I think it's going to make
a big difference in November electoral
college ban do the math he's president
let America vote and host the podcast
with Geordi 54 Jason Kander everyone
[Music]